justin is so confident as a visual
storyteller and breeze the story to life
with such specificity and such power
it's easy to get dust the new vastness
of space it was great working with
Justin he bought you know wonderful
fresh energy to the project he was
plucked from that kind of indie
filmmaking to helm a franchise like fast
and furious as often happens these days
big studios will will find promising
young directors and and give them huge
enterprises you've pardon the pun - sort
of - come on I think you're under
estimating humanity justin was able to
come in and bring his intimate knowledge
of Star Trek in the Star Trek characters
at being a long-term fan and work
together with Simon and Doug our writers
to really deliver something to an
audience that you know we'll only pays
homage to the 50 years but also delivers
a real sort of thrill seeker ride I
think Justin brings the sensitivity of
his early filmmaking with his fantastic
understanding of motion and intention
and pacing and action he's a perfect
combination for this film you know
because that is hopefully what this is
it's a combination of of emotion and
real relationships set against a
backdrop of spectacular action
with any of these big films we have to
have a good story and you have to have
characters that you care about an
emotional journey that you really
attached to him and Justin as a believer
in that and just like Jesu was in the
first two films he marries incredible
incredible action cinematic sequences
with a story that's simple and emotional
and touching and I think that's all you
can ask for for a film of this size and
scope I've been very fortunate I
inherited all-star cast and on top of
that we were able to add you know
interest alba sofia boutella and it
makes my job so much easier when
everybody's coming in for the right
reason everybody's coming in and
contributing and so you know day by day
you just keep seeing the quality go up
because there's just so much you know
emotion and passion committed to the
film Wow at least I won't die alone
well that's just filmmaking is not just
one person it takes hundreds of people
sometimes thousands of people to fill
the world and to be able to be around
that group of you know passionate
individuals it really truly is a gift
it's a privilege to be able to be a part
of this franchise is a privilege to be
able to get this group people and to
bring something this ambitious July